now at noon mask up to stop the spread
with new rules in effect now in clark
county
we're breaking down who does and who
does not need to cover their face
plus booster shot or not a new study
targets one vaccine maker
but infectious disease experts are not
convinced convinced
we'll explain and get some satisfaction
when the rolling stones come to town
will tell you when
and where and when you can score some
tickets
now this is eight news now live at noon
live local now thanks for joining us
here at noon i'm hector mejia we start
today in clark county where a brand new
mask
requirement is now in effect in hopes of
slowing down
an increase in cases largely due to the
delta variant
employees who work in public places will
now need to cover their face
the clark county commission made the
decision earlier this week to a lot of
mixed reaction
customers in stores for example are not
required to mask up
leaving many to wonder how this will be
effective
they're telling us now we've got to wear
masks as employees
whether you're vaccinated or not and
that's okay
but they're telling us that customers
don't have to wear masks
and like who are we protecting
officials say vaccines are the best way
to get a grip on case numbers
they add vaccines are free safe
effective and available to everyone but
there's still
a lot of hesitancy speaking of the
coronavirus the requirement came from a
steady rise in covet infections
let's dive into the latest numbers
nevada is reporting a 12.7 positivity
rate while clark county reports
14 942 new cases were reported
along with eight deaths the majority of
those in clark county
as of now only about 47 percent of
nevadans are fully vaccinated